you know jake paul is on the warpath for
trying to get mma fighters paid more at
least that's what we that's what he's
projecting and that's the message that
he always has that he's on their side
now is he using that as just a little
way to dig dana white and keep that
front and center in front of his face so
the story this past week was the
sparring partner jake paul has had for
the last two months said he made more
money being paid by jake paul for
sparring with him getting him ready for
this fight that he made his entire
career at bellator okay so that's a
great headline and everything but when
you peel it back a little bit the guy
was two and three so it's not like he
was a great fighter in belatar you got
to win you've got to have main events to
make the real money i have a very good
friend who's a champion in belatar he
earned it
he's he gets paid big bucks for a reason
this guy didn't so here's my quick
thoughts on on jake paul in this whole
topic for him and then i'm going to turn
it over to paul
and phil here in just a second and my
advice for jake paul would be be very
careful when you're dealing with dana
white because there's a difference
between being what you are jake paul
which is a master marketer a good boxer
you know a very famous and popular
person
but
he's on a different level dana white is
different dana white is a businessman
he's ruthless he's powerful and he
doesn't give a damn about your following
on youtube and i think this works for
you for what you're looking to
accomplish in boxing and
you're using the topic of getting mma
fighters and ufc fighters paid more
because you think they're grossly
underpaid but be very very careful
because you need dana white you need
he has to sign off anytime you want to
fight these ufc fighters you can't fight
boxers because boxing's dead so i would
equate almost this like a grizzly bear
out in the wilderness and and a youtube
star is messing with the grizzly bear
and he's throwing rocks at him and he's
poking him with a stick and he's
shooting him in the eye with a squirt
gun funny stuff great content but
eventually that grizzly bear is gonna
peel back and backhand you and separate
your face from your cranium if you're
not careful so my advice would be tread
lightly around dana white because he's a
good sport and he's taking it for now
but um he could put a stop to this
pretty darn quickly and i'll start with
you paul and when you watch this and you
see what's going on you've seen jake
paul talk about this how they only get
10 of the actual revenue that's driven
in the ufc compared to like 50 in the
nba what do you think his agenda is this
is just another way to prop up his
fights turn himself into this the
spotlight on him in boxing or do you
think he's really fighting for the
fighters in the ufc
if there's a business model component to
this like he wants to go kind of like
the oscar de la hoya route or uh floyd
mayweather where he's maybe looking to
end up in like the promotional game then
uh you know i think it's a great
strategy because then again there's some
sort of end game to it if this is just
a an extension of
building up his own brand then
that could end up you know kind of
biting him in the ass a little bit you
know i've been in phil i've been in um
dana white's office in las vegas i spent
a day with him one time and i did a big
story with him he's just fascinating i'm
a big fan of dana white and everything
he's built with the ufc but his office
is truly unbelievable when you go into
his office you know that they don't have
an hr department at the ufc okay that is
the one thing that strikes you because
he's got he's got this coffee table that
has actual cocaine in it and drugs and a
gun in it i forgot what the details were
of it but it's an unbelievable little
piece of art that represented maybe a
big drug deal gone bad or something with
a cartel or something but there's a
story behind everything very interesting
artwork and what nothing and phil you
were in a sport where
it wasn't you didn't have a league no
one was paying you you had to make
sponsorships prize money it was you
against everybody else you either won or
you didn't what do you think ufc
fighters if you were hearing that
they're making 10 percent and what they
put on the line just to get into the
ring and get into the octagon what's
your take on that first of all i think
he's finessing this whole situation i
mean i think he's
it's not a promotional game you know
like you're talking about paul i
actually think that he's just leveraging
the hell out of these fighters that are
maybe no longer relevant in the ufc
and just catapulting his own brand off
of their likeness
you know at the end of the day
we'll have to see
him lose for us to kind of
figure out like okay does this really
help the ufc fighters yeah but at the
end of the day i agree with you
there's no reason to poke the bearer
named dana white there is no freaking
way because i mean the man dana white
has already gone through wars he's
already gone through you know major
business deals and stuff like that for
all we know the art of war could already
be in his back pocket saying like okay
jake like you keep doing what you're
doing
but i've got a million other ways to
litigate against your ass i got a
million other ways to block other deals
and but the good thing is is that dana
is a highly competitive person and i
really applaud that because he just
welcomes the [ __ ] like he just is like
come on like let's go and paul does as
well and i think that
i don't necessarily agree with the
strategy but it again it goes on brand
with with with jake and logan paul is it
they're they're going to keep staying
relevant and dana white is that name
kind of like how people you know uh in
the trump days would go after trump it
automatically moves your article up oh
absolutely they did it to me in
bodybuilding trust me like when they
want to get their name up they're going
to mention phil heath and these
bodybuilding circles and stuff so i
understand that personally but on that
level i mean we're talking about billion
dollar guys here i mean we're talking
about like dana white yeah and here's
the other thing too is i think the topic
that he's bringing up because i bet you
a lot of these ufc fighters are
perfectly happy with what they make i
mean some fighters that come from
nothing and they're getting paid ten
thousand fifteen thousand twenty five
what whatever it is and they know if
they are more successful they'll get
paid more but he's planting that seed in
there that you're underpaid it's almost
like going into an amazon warehouse and
trying to start a union where people
weren't thinking about it and thought
hey i like the benefits i like working
for amazon but let me think about that
what i'm not getting five weeks of paid
vacation uh my health benefits aren't
this i'm not getting that you start
thinking about what you don't have and
he's planted that seed that could that
could grow and become a real problem for
him and here's what he's doing to dana
white he's not just messing with them
and trolling him he's essentially saying
that dana white doesn't care about ufc
fighters and that's a very very personal
thing to say and that that is something
that would get somebody pissed off very
very quickly and look to squash you if
he possibly could and whites has that
reputation i mean
uh um
liddell right chuck ladell there's a lot
of critics that say hey you know he
should have never fought those last
couple fights you know like you're not
looking out for your guy
yeah i put him in the ring it's it's it
doesn't have that great reputation true
but that's that's a fine line to walk
because you are running a business right
and chuck liddell was the biggest star
you throw out him out there and the
pay-per-views just start ringing the
cash register i mean we all know like if
you if you want to make it big
you go to ufc
yeah period yeah you know you look at
conor mcgregor he started in ufc yeah
you know yeah and he [ __ ] and he moaned
you know with dana and stuff but at the
end of the day i mean
he still worked with dana to go figure
out a path to where he could get paid
more money because remember back in the
day you know conor was like look i need
to get paid more money like i'm
producing but he had the numbers yeah
see it's very difficult where
you know you can't just expect just
because you're a pro that you're
automatically going to get signed to
these contracts you're not guaranteed
[ __ ] like you're not like you can't
assume that anymore we live in a society
today where they're looking at
your engagement on social media they're
looking at just your overall likeness
they have so many different algorithms
and you know data points that are gonna
tell
the owner like hey he's worth fifty
thousand dollars for an appearance or a
hundred thousand dollars or whatever i
tell all the all the bodybuilders same
way i would tell a ufc guy
enhance your freaking likeness
show that you have some value outside of
what your craft is
because that's what jake paul and logan
paul they'll pay you accordingly and
then they'll pay you the money will come
to you it'll find you by the way if you
were looking for something to do and
logan paul started talking smack started
ripping up your your center folds from
back of the day when you're posing he
challenges you would you get in the ring
would you start training for boxing take
three months and go in there and fight
him i just think that's stupid like you
don't play boxing yeah you just don't
like you know it's not an eagle contest
that that'd be like me saying hey come
train with me and i'm gonna put you
through these workouts you probably pull
all kind of muscles and stuff like that
you know
at the end of the day you know i was
actually you know asked you know hey
would you ever do like a celebrity
boxing this and say absolutely not
because i'm not i'm i'm not going to
disrespect a sport number one like you
don't play boxing you don't play mma
like you know these are this is a very
high intense contact sport where someone
could die through that but here's the
difference here's the difference right
now the paul brothers are the most
relevant thing in the entire sport of
boxing they are the
number one reason people tune into
boxing i mean manny pacquiao tried to
get it going again at the age of 42 who
would pay for that crap
but
then again
boxing needs to look at
hey who are our guys right now
and actually have some type of
conversation with some of these
champions or up and comers and say hey
look we need to have a strategy session
as to how
you know we can promote you but it also
comes with the athletes the athletes
have to establish some type of team
to go to the you know the powers that be
in these organizations and say hey look
this is what i want to do i'm gonna i'm
gonna fight on short notice i'm gonna
fight here i'm gonna fight there i'm
gonna promote i'm gonna i'm gonna do
those appearances that the normal guy
won't do
but i need backing i need sponsors i
need i need i need ideas we've been
saying that about boxing for a very long
time i think the number one thing they
should do is look for a third paul
brother see if they could find another
one and start growing and boxing's the
most popular it's ever been i mean
that's a sad thing because of jake and
because of involvement yeah i mean
klitschko is the last guy i kind of
remember i mean besides mayweather of
course but so are we so are we going to
expect
tyron to lose
yeah are we going in i think
i'm going to say this right now i think
i think jake paul is a legitimate boxer
yeah i think he's head and shoulders
above his brother logan i think he's a
tactician i think he's getting great
training i think he's an outstanding
boxer and i think he's going to win it's
for the simple fact that woodley is
taking it for the paycheck and has no
experience in boxing you just don't
learn
a couple weeks so then what is what is
the next move after that does he fight
an actual real boxer after that i can
tell you what i think it's going to be
here is the end game as i see it for the
paul brothers and i really firmly
believe this and you know they bought
each other well they made their
headquarters down here they're going to
go through their list here in miami here
in south florida where we are so they're
going through their list of c list mma
fighters washed up boxers big names here
and there and they're going to keep
winning they're going to keep they might
lose one here or there or get a draw
like they did with meriwether or
mayweather but they're gonna be the
number one thing in boxing now look
where the money's coming from it's
coming from showtime all right so
they're off that little app right now
and they jake paul is backed by showtime
just like oscar de la hoya or somebody
back in the day so here's how it's gonna
go down these guys are both gonna take
about five more fights over the course
of a year and a half or two years keep
building this keep talking smack at the
ufc because ultimately jake paul doesn't
need the ufc unless he only wants to
fight conor mcgregor this is leading to
jake versus logan for nine figures each
they will each make a hundred million
it'll be the biggest thing it'll be
family against family it'll be three
months of build up
and i think that's what's going to
happen in a couple years who doesn't
want to watch that everybody will pay
for it watch it well the formula is
there right i mean if we're already
prophesizing it it's probably already
been talked about a couple years ago and
i could definitely see it happening you
know unfortunately i think the the
current boxers out there are not
speaking out enough and saying look like
i want some of that let's make that
happen yeah the ufc guys that are that
are taking these fights at the end of
the day i mean i respect their craft i
think they're all badasses and i met a
lot of them but i i definitely believe
that if you go ahead and fight these
guys
it's it's not about if you're doing a
cash grabbing you're going for that bag
make sure that you have like another
three to five moves after that to you
know whether it be writing books or
whatever because i don't see you ever
going back to another boxing event let
alone another mma event well and you
mentioned something earlier about uh
like the athletes taking their own uh
kind of taking their own uh um the
ownership from the brand yeah and and
while you're speaking i went back to uh
rocky iii and remember how you know mr t
clubber lang you know went after rocky
and kind of coerced him and so if if
we're calling the pauls like a rocky you
need if if if other boxers that are
actually serious and want to be on that
pedestal like they have to come after
them and then kind of make that name
that they don't want to do that because
they they went through a different route
to become a pro yeah and you know they
they probably sit on their high horses
like look man i had 100 fights as an
amateur and stuff like that to even like
who am i i don't want to go down to his
level and stuff when really in all
seriousness we're dealing with an
influencer game right now yeah you got
to just say hey woman you know
there's no boxer that's relevant there's
zero we just came off the olympics every
other time we have an olympiad we become
we fall in love with an american boxer i
couldn't tell you one if my life
depended on it there is no boxer out
there that's gonna move the needle
whatsoever at all here's the difference
the paul brothers are marketers who can
really box okay you have boxers that
have no idea how to be marketers so
they're gonna they're gonna grab all the
spotlight right now and they're
interesting and i'm rooting for them you
know i hope jake paul wins i think he's
working hard and becoming a legitimate
boxer and i don't like it when guys
think they can just jump in there and
and hang with them but i think it'll be
entertaining and i'll watch it i watch
the logan paul fight i'll watch this one
too yeah i got to watch it yeah
i could not so i'll see you guys
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]